I went in there with just wanting a
nose job and my lips done and he made me
feel like my entire face was messed up.
I left in tears because
I felt I am so hideous.
My name is Shana.
I do anti aging research and consulting.
My Name Is Tanisha Aka the Lego Queen.
Um,
I do a lot of advocacy for
vitiligo awareness. Hi, I'm
Rena and I'm an actress.
My name is Carly.
I'm a healthy lifestyle coach.
My name is Sagar Patel and I'm a facial
plastic surgeon in Beverly hills.
My name is Nicola Lowery.
I am a physician assistant
practicing aesthetic medicine.
I've been practicing for 14 years and
I'm a national trainer for Allergan.
The makers of Botox and
fillers and I please
have my natural beauty folks on the left
and my cosmetic surgery group on the
right.
Yeah,
the cosmetic surgery industry
exploits people's insecurities.
I don't think the industry as
a whole does it's money, right?
So I think there are,
there's the motivation behind women
not feeling good about themselves.
And I do think there are certain companies
and individuals who would exploit
that in order to make it more lucrative
for them. It just makes sense.
That's how businesses work.
Some places where they tell you like bring
out those insecurities because I want
them to buy these products. You mean like
in a training they tell you that. Right,
and I'm not going to do that to
someone is like, oh well you have this,
this and this wrong.
Maybe you want to fix it.
I'm not going to do that to somebody and
create an insecurity in them that maybe
they knew they had and not playing
on it or maybe they didn't know,
but now they do. Definitely. I was
only 18 when I called from my console.
I said I would like to have a consult
for a rhinoplasty and lip injections and
he gave me the,
I needed chicken plans.
I needed to have my brow line shaved down
because changing my nose would change
the entire shape of my fees and I felt
very much so like he just saw me as
money.
Okay.
There's good doctors and
bad doctors and in the end,
the important thing to realize is that
doctors are trying to do good for other
people.
There's exceptions,
but it's a professional society where
our goal is to help other people and you
know, initially going in to the
cosmetic world especially, um,
it's a multibillion dollar industry
and as a doctor you're always taught a
couple of laurels from
benevolence to do no harm.
Insecurity is inherent in all of us. Some
of us have more, some of us have less,
but it was already there and you know,
does the cosmetic industry
capitalize on our insecurities? Sure.
I think that there is a piece of that,
but as all industries that are just
trying to market to the people that are
going to utilize it, right. Product,
I wish I could change
something about my appearance.
Yeah. I feel like, um,
just because I want to change something
about myself doesn't necessarily mean
that I don't accept myself.
Those are the thoughts that prompt me to,
to work on acceptance of myself.
Something that I come across a lot in
my practice is not so much that someone
wants to change the way that they look,
but they want to preserve it.
There's a lot of issues,
especially with women
with the aging process.
It's not so much that they
want to be somebody else,
so they want to look like somebody else,
but they want to stay looking like them.
I fully intend to do a facelift when the
time is right and not because I want to
look different,
but because I want to continue
to look as young as I feel. Yeah.
I think for me,
um,
major decision for me to get cosmetic
surgery was that I was in my early
twenties and I had had a massive weight
loss. I naturally lost the weight.
Um,
I lost 175 pounds and my skin
looked like a nine year old.
So for me, I consider it more
like reconstructive and, um,
kind of getting back to what I was
supposed to be before I did some damage to
myself. For me. Um,
I spent my entire childhood and into
my early adult life wishing I looked
different.
I promised myself that I would never,
ever tell myself I wish I had this.
I wish I looked like this because
I found that triggered, um,
things for me that brought back places
that I used to be with my eating disorder.
I think that's great,
and I hope you don't take offense to this,
but you're gorgeous.
And I feel like if I was okay,
if I was naturally that, like beautiful,
it wouldn't be that hard to like be like,
oh my God, my face is gorgeous. You
know, I'm going to accept myself.
There are people who have facial
deformities and embodied to, for me,
it's like w kind of what I consider what
I went through. It's a little harder.
Yeah. Oh, definitely. Yes.
Might have a pretty face,
but I was always the largest of all of
my friends, the largest of my family,
five years of my life.
I spent constantly,
constantly waking up in the morning and
picking apart every single part of my
body.
I can't continue this constant,
terrible habit of bulemia or I'm
going to die. Yeah. Okay, good.
Just I was horribly believing for a year
and a half, like it was awful. Yeah.
So I got it. Yeah. Yeah. It's not easy.
Cosmetic surgery can empower you.
I do wish that every woman could wake
up and look in the mirror and be like,
I am so beautiful just the way I am.
But I also think that if you can do
something to give yourself that feeling,
then that's really great and that,
that is a beautiful thing.
So one of the questions we actually
asked on our questionnaires,
what are your motivations for surgery?
And someone who says,
I can't get a boyfriend.
You know,
I'm getting bad grades because
I have this particular look,
they're a bad candidate for surgery.
And you know,
that's part of medical school training.
That's part of becoming a surgeon is
understanding what these triggers are.
What are the signs that
tell you as a surgeon,
this is not going to be someone
who's going to be happy afterwards,
whether or not you are
inherently truly happy or not.
I think that's hugely important.
But what if you're a happy person but
you hate your nose or would if you're a
very happy person and you were born with
a cleft palate and you want to be able
to project your image to the world
that's congruent with how you feel on the
inside and maybe you're experiencing
negativity because of the way you were
born.
Naturally
every day. I experience stories
of empowerment with patients,
but for me a particular one comes
essentially from someone who was so
okay.
Unempowered by her
experiences. This girl, uh,
she was 23 at the time,
um,
was beat by her father when
she was younger and sustained
significant trauma to
her nose and helping her and fixing her
nose and the gratitude she showed and
realizing that you didn't
help her for that day.
You didn't help her for that week.
It's for the rest of her life. She, it,
she can start moving on.
And that empowerment is one of,
is a perfect example of
what cosmetic surgery.
And that truly was that it
was just a cosmetic surgery.
It was not so she could breathe.
It wasn't so she could move around better.
It was to make her look a certain way
so she doesn't have to remember that
experience.
There's too much pressure on
women to look a certain way.
We live in a instant life now with,
you know we have dating apps or you can
swipe hundreds of people a day and you
know,
you can go online and post a good
selfie of yourself and get you know,
hundreds of likes and you feel like
there's so much pressure to look and be a
certain way,
like you can never fall.
Kind of looked at the way that
things have changed around pregnancy.
A lot of women now want to go
and have a baby with a beat face.
Like everything's perfect.
It's about the perfect picture.
I have to have my makeup and my brows now.
I understand some things.
You just want to be perfect.
I get it. I want to,
I want to be able just embrace the moments
with my child and not worry about all
this makeup. I have one right now. I think
we've been kind of comparing, you know,
say the 25 year old to the 25 year old,
but then let's think about the women that
are middle aged and are having to keep
up with the younger girls,
it to try and still feel attractive
and relevant. And I do see that a lot,
even with my clientele. I have women that
are married to very wealthy men. Yeah.
And that their greatest fear is that
they will end up becoming the second wife
because the new and improved wife is
on her way in and she's on her way out.
So this pressure to maintain youth and
beauty and relevance is so huge for not
really realizing that it's that men,
there's a jerk
and it's like, it's my,
it's not the, it's not us.
It's really the person that you're with.
And so I think that always happened
to keep up with the Joneses and always
wanted to just like,
I have to look this way because this
person has to love me and if this person
doesn't love me,
I'm going to have to,
I have to make myself be
who he loves to take it to.
A lot of pressure.
Yeah,
I am beautiful.
Okay.
Okay. So I'm going to go first because I
woke up this morning and I really loved
myself with me having a bit of Lego.
It took a long time.
When I first was diagnosed at five,
no one knew what it was.
Everyone thought Michael Jackson
made it up. It's a real thing.
No one knew that it was real.
So a lot of people's first
time encountering would
it actually look like in
person was me. I took a long
time for me to get to this point.
So where I'm just like,
oh, I love who I am.
I'm super beautiful for things that I do.
Not particularly how I look,
how cute he is ever. You know,
my browser. Nice. And you know, that's it.
But I feel still beautiful for the way
that I make other people feel and just
hike how I love myself. One of the
things that happened with me, um,
gaining the weight really fast and then
losing it really fast as I have a lot of
stretch marks. I have a friend who's
really into body positivity and um,
she's a photographer and she took pictures
of these ugly parts of me and she's
just like, wow, that is so beautiful.
And like I could see through her eyes,
like I'm starting to
see myself in that way.
Even those things that will never get
fixed, there is no way to fix them.
There was no way to replace my skin
with other skin. It's different,
but it's beautiful.
There's one message that I
wanted to get out to men today.
A simple thing like someone telling you,
you look beautiful without being creepy,
of course. Um, but someone just
telling you, you look beautiful.
All of you guys look beautiful.
That makes a big difference to everyone
and tell people they're beautiful
because men are beautiful too.
Correct.
Thank you guys for this experience.
You guys are amazing.
Thank you guys.
Hi Guys. My name is Aaron
and I'm from jubilee media.
I really hope you enjoyed this video
and took something away from both sides.
We really try to encourage people to
listen to others because we believe that's
the first step to change.
And so check out our other work.
Tell us what you think below and we
hope you will watch another video of our
soon.